In this video, we are going to introduce you
with one of the most plausible theories out
there,
in which fierce Lyanna Mormont who killed
a giant at the age of 13, becoming a gianstbane
herself,
was the daughter of none other than Tormund
Giantsbane who also slew a giant at the age
of 10.
Like father, like daughter...
Lyanna's mother, Maege Mormont, the she-bear
was the lady of Bear Island
and the head of House Mormont.
In the books, she has many daughters and in
the show, she had only one, Lyanna, namesake
of Lyanna Stark, Lord Eddard Stark's sister(sibling).
There are indications that Maege Mormont had
an affair with Tormund
and it resulted with a great warrior, Lyanna
Mormont.
The sigil of House Mormont is a bear surrounded
by white with green borders.
Just like Lyanna Stark was called the she-wolf
due to the wolf being the sigil of her house,
Maege Mormont was known in the North as the
she-bear.
Tormund boasts of having bedded a she-bear.
There's a scene on the show when Tormund explains
how he came by this name.
In the mentioned scene, Tormund boasts to
Jon Snow that he once accidentally seduced
a bear during an intense snowstorm, believing
she was merely a stout, hot-tempered woman,
which funny enough is exactly how Maege Mormont
is described in the books.
When Tormund awoke, he was badly scratched
and there was a ''she-bear pelt'' lying on
the ground.
In addition to all these clues, no one knows
who the father of Lyanna is or even if Maege
ever married.
Nonetheless, all of Maege's daughters
and on the show her only daughter Lyanna carry
the surname Mormont
and none appear to be considered bastards.
It's possible that Maege's husband came from
a family of a lower nobility than the Mormonts
or no nobility at all, in which case a woman
can prefer to retain her own surname for herself
and for her children.
One of many of Tormund's nicknames is Husband
to Bears.
In the books, Maege's other daughter, Alysane,
smilingly shares the rumor claiming that Mormont
women are skinchangers
who turn into bears and find mates in the
woods.
In fact, Alysane claims her two children are
fathered by bears.
One of the titles of Tormund Giantsbane is
Father To Bears,
meaning that some of the Mormonts may have
wilding blood.
On the gate of Mormont's hall is a carving
of a woman in a bearskin
with a child in one arm suckling at her breast
and a battleaxe in the other.
It's also mentioned that women of House Mormont
learned how to defend themselves from wildlings
who avoided the Wall entirely by using boats
to cross the bay from the Froyen Shore on
the other side.
So we know the wildlings were sometimes raiding
their lands.
Perhaps that's how Maege and Tormund met and
fell in love,
and the byproduct of that love may have been
Lyanna Mormont.
The show didn't confirm this, in my opinion
probably the most plausible theory in the
Game of Thrones realm, but there's still hope
for the books to do the deed
and hopefully, Lyanna survives the fight against
the giant in the books, just like Tormund
did.
On the bright side of the show version, at
least House Mormont and all of its members
did not suffer the same fate as all other
characters, which is being butchered by season
8.
Ironically they were slain, but not by writing,
but by their bravery and loyalty.
Here they stand, true to their words, both
Jorah and Lyanna stood their ground defending
Winterfell.
In conclusion, there's a high possibility
that Lyanna Mormont was on the show
and still is in the books the daughter of
Tormund Giantsbane,
the Husband to Bears and the Father to Bears
and the she-bear he bedded was none other
than the she-bear Maege Mormont.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed this video and if you did
please give it a big thumbs up and I hope
to see you in the next one!
Peace